le bicentenaire concerne comme vous le
savez les grands et les petits ne serait
ce à propos des petits que pour
apprendre l'histoire tout simplement
cela dit ça fait pas de mal au rang de
rafraîchir leurs connaissances
concernant les acteurs de la révolution
ces quelques petites choses tout de même
mais au moment au même moment que
faisait les enfants de cette époque et
bien être joués me direz vous mais à
quoi
alors voici à la réponse c'est hull à
une exposition présentée à bourges et
qu'à visiter l'un des grands enfants
carré d'as louis vincent guay la
révolution ont joué beaucoup au jeu de
massacre
les boîtes peu des vedettes de l'époque
à qui il était arrivé des drôles de
trucs exemple mara mais non pas
charlotte bidule charlotte corday autre
jeu très prisé la marelle beaucoup plus
pacifique et réserver bien entendu aux
antilles contrairement à un autre jeu
pour les plus grands et surtout pour les
jeunes gens et qui met tout ça vous
connaissiez déjà au xviiie siècle qu'on
pratiquait le jeu du tonneau et oui le
fameux jeu du tonneau une sorte de
loterie ou le joueur essaie de viser des
trouées et marquer ainsi des points
l'ancêtre du lot tour quel que soit
encore plus connus la montgolfière
la montgolfière mais entendu était très
à la mode parce que dans toute la région
parisienne on a vu des montgolfières
s'élever mais les enfants se sont mis en
fabriquer en papier alors on en trouvait
partout dans tous les sapins aujourd'hui
il n'en reste pas beaucoup des jouets de
la révolution on les garde précieusement
dans des vitrines
il n'y avait pas de magasin et on en
faisait souvent avec des bouts de bois
exception pourtant une guillotine
miniatures et comment ça marche une
guillotine
eh ben on me dit oui ces journées ce
terreau dans ton regard quelqu'un de la
révolution ici comme ça est attaché
ensuite on met vous mettez à diète mais
là comme ça mettez la tête ici et après
vue d'initier à guillotine qui tombait
et qui est fait passer dans le panier il
s'était bien utile pour ceux qui disent
aux billets qui désobéissent et à la
révolution
ça c'était normal moi je trouve que ça
va juste ça sera bleu met en prison les
tuer leur couper la terre avant c'était
la terreur oui je ne pouvais pas les
mettre aux prises au discours là on a
tout détruit la bastide bon enfin les
filles elles l avaient des poupées pour
jouer des polichinelles une heure au
ventre oui même s'il faudra qu'ils
mangent pour qu'ils arrêtent de manger
pour moi elle est géniale on dira troll
avec ce rapprochement
huawei qui parle qui chante les mails
solide que les vous plaît d'aujourd'hui
oui céline et ben oui du temps la
révolution il y a deux cents ans on en
fabrique est pas beaucoup des jouets et
ceux qui avaient une guillotine
miniatures ou un polichinelle et ben
c'était des petits veinards